and joining me now with reaction former
deputy assistant to the president Fox
News national security strategist
Sebastian Gorka and former Secret
Service agent NRA TV contributor Dan
Mangino dr. korkor we start with you
though you know for everybody that has
been so critical Oh
rocket man I can assure and I'll address
this in my monologue tonight I can
assure the world that he's not going to
be offering a hundred and fifty billion
dollars in cash and other foreign
currencies nor will he be offering what
Bill Clinton gave Kim jong-un's father
Kim jong-il and that was energy and
billions of dollars it's truly
incredible Shawn what a massive
difference one election makes we have an
administration that's not going to
kowtow to evil regimes it's not going to
fund terrorist regimes as you rightly
pointed out with the jcpoa Ron deal
American leadership is back we have a
president who has walked the walk talk
the talk and carried a very large stick
he stood up to this Stalinist
dictatorship in North Korea and what's
happened in the matter of just a few
months they've backed down and they want
to talk after decades and decades of
appeasement this is the vindication of
the president's foreign policy after the
crushing of Isis this is perhaps the
biggest foreign policy win that we have
seen and it's it's less than a year and
a half into the administration this is a
problem that has plagued the West played
the Pacific region for decades and
finally there's hope of resolution
remember what Reagan said trust but
verify but we are on the way to
stabilizing the peninsula yeah well said
and and Dan bonds you know by showing
strength and a commitment one thing that
I don't think a lot of people have
understood is the effect the impact
these sanctions have had China the
president's relationship with China has
put a lot of pressure and China has
withdrawn a lot of their financial
support and trade as it relates to North
Korea that has played a part in it and
also America's military force in the
region but as shown by the president it
was there was no
question what the consequences would be
if Kim jong-un continued what he was
doing and firing these missiles there he
was precipitating a crisis the president
would strike it would have happened it
was inevitable absolutely it showed a
couple points on this you know what are
the lessons a lot of these hostile geo
political actors learned around the
world after the Iraq war was never ever
go to war with the United States without
nuclear weapons you will be annihilated
and annihilated quickly well the Kim
regime learned from that and they've
been holding a the threat of nuclear war
like a gun to the head of the world now
for years but think about what happened
they took advantage of our
predictability on this Shawn and we've
been predictable through Democrat and
Republican administrations then we get a
Queen's Builder in office who drops a
couple DEFCON 1 level tweets in there
he's entirely unpredictable and all of a
sudden they want to chat about
denuclearization I think Trump deserves
that even from his liberal haters and
they are many and Legion in the media
alert deserves a little bit of credit
for what dr. Gork has said he's right a
major major foreign policy breakthrough
you know very predictably dr. corkage
the left only seems to like it if we're
bowing kissing the rings of murdering
dictators and offering them bribes while
offering bribes with Bill Clinton and
Kim jong-il didn't work it's not going
to work with the mullahs in Tehran and
this president took a very different
response and it absolutely sent the
media in this country they were
apoplectic over the fact that he call
them little rocket man little rocket man
make fun of him yeah our weapons
actually work and there we have a lot
more than you do and you're going to pay
a very severe price but the one thing
one consistent thing that we see is we
look through history is that
capitulation and appeasement never works
peace through strength it's not just a
slogan it is a philosophy in the only
way to get respect is to stand strong in
the face of tyranny right as we did
twice during the 20th century in America
saved Western civilization saved
judeo-christian civilization from the
Nazis and then the car
- I just want to see the headlines
tomorrow Sean in the New York Times The
Washington Post on CNN in The Huffington
Post that they're gonna eat crow because
the president's policies worked you know
what what the the real irony is guess
who got the Nobel Peace Prize
the man who flamed out with his foreign
policy Barack Obama who deserves a Peace
Prize right now it's Donald Trump for
what he's bringing to the Korean
Peninsula that's the truth let me go
damn Bonjean Oh to the actual statement
and I think this is really profound and
I brought this up with John Roberts and
John Roberts insight into the president
I'm not trying to start a war I want
peace here but peace doesn't begin by
begging dictators to be nice to us if we
even if we're nice to you and bribe you
please be nice back but this is bigger
than just stopping the nuclear testing
and the missile testing that's been
going on this is about denuclearization
and in the meantime the joint exercises
continue with South America and our
allies in the meantime the sanctions
continue the president has given up
nothing and it seems like little
Rocketman blinked and blinked big time
tonight because it's been working and he
sees this as a real threat yeah he does
see it as a real threat you know
strength matters but don't expect
anybody on the left of the media Shawn
to give him any credit for this as we
saw with Reagan and his crushing of the
Soviet Union they went after Reagan not
the Soviet Union they're just like they
did by the way when they went after
Trump when he went after North Korean of
the North Korean leader a sworn enemy of
the United States you know the left and
the media spent an inordinate amount of
time fighting fake enemies you know
inanimate statues and things like that
and leaving the real enemies of the
United States alone but I think dr. Gork
is right I think there's going to be a
whole lot of servings of grow getting
ready to be served tomorrow to the media
in the left this is unquestionably a
major breakthrough I I haven't I was
actually astonished by this tonight when
it yeah we came back here in the
Olympics Oh Kim jong-un's a sister made
Mike Pence look bad which never happened
and that was the media's narrative
plea oh my god he's provoking World War
3 he said little ROK
man the one thing that it seems that we
forget is we are the United States of
America we have the meanest toughest
military on the face of this earth
reminding dictators that they cannot
intimidate us is not a bad foreign
policy but if it encourages them to
reach out for peace we offer our hand in
peace because the world ultimately is
better off for our children and
grandchildren it's not that complicated
dr. Gorka it's not and I'll let me share
with you I was in the Oval by myself
with the president maybe back in May and
he just looked up from his desk and he
said I do not want to go to war on the
Korean Peninsula but he understands when
a threat is made and he loves our
military and he understands him I took
18 Green Berets into the Oval the way he
connected with them was incredible he
understands that diplomacy means nothing
unless you have the option for force to
back it up and that's what we've
forgotten for far too long and whether
it's a moab bomb in Afghanistan whether
it's cruise missiles in Syria he's not
an adventurist but he will stand up to
evil as we have done so many times
before and I just want to know how the
never Trump is are going to react
how are the Tom Friedman's how are the
sad individuals like Mac's booed going
to react now when Donald Trump's
policies keep winning and as you
mentioned it I think the steel tariff is
part of this deal absolutely and I'll
get to that later in the program tonight
well said dr. korkor thank you dan
bungee no thank you